[Musique]
est-elle là encore
pas encore maman non
alors elle est en retard
oui
elle est en retard
[Musique]
tu es notre altesse
maman la
famille sont tous réunis dans le
salon ils attendent
[Musique]
trois jours
ça y est
ils s'arrangent  sérieux à propos de toi
alors reste immobile et souris beaucoup
ils savent tout
[Musique]
ils ne savent pas
maman ce qui s'est passé pour te rendre si triste
eh bien ouais
il n'y a pas de futur passé et les cadeaux
sont la même chose
diana
ils ne peuvent pas te changer  tu dois changer
[Musique]
tu dois pouvoir faire des choses que tu
détestes tu détestes il faut que vous soyez deux
c'est le vrai
et celui qu'ils prennent en photo
diana
pour le bien du pays
[Musique]
combats les tu es ton  propre arme
[Musique
] Vont-ils me tuer pensez-vous
[Musique]
vous